hacer hincapié en un futuro cercano".
Y, desde luego, estamos hablando de drones,
una tecnología que no solo es poco popular en Occidente
sino que se ha convertido en una realidad
muy desagradable para muchos que viven en países pobres,
sobre todo aquellos que están involucrados en conflictos.
Entonces, ¿por qué estamos haciendo esto?
Bien, elegimos hacer esto
no solo porque era fácil
sino porque podemos causar un impacto asombroso.
Imaginen a mil millones de personas conectadas
a los bienes materiales de la misma forma
que los sistemas de telecomunicaciones móviles les conectan
a la información.
Imaginen si la próxima gran red que construyéramos en el mundo
fuera una red de transporte de materiales.
En el mundo desarrollado, esperaríamos
llegar a millones de personas con mejores vacunas
llegar a ellos con mejores medicinas.
Nos daría una ventaja decisiva en la lucha contra
el virus del SIDA y VIH, la tuberculosis y otras epidemias.
Con el tiempo, esperaríamos que se convirtiera
en una nueva plataforma para transacciones económicas
sacando a millones de personas de la pobreza.
En el mundo desarrollado y emergente,
esperaríamos que se convirtiera en una nueva forma
de transporte que pudiera ayudar a hacer nuestras ciudades
más habitables.
A quienes aún creen que esto es ciencia ficción,
les digo firmemente que no lo es.
Pero debemos involucrarnos
en la ficción social para hacer que suceda.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)